you were a hairdresser for nine years so
you worked for nine years are you
working at the salon and every week
watching SNL and going I'm better than
those people I could be on that show I
will say this is so weird and I I don't
consider myself a cocky person I'm doing
hair I would watch SNL because I was
like such a fan forever I knew that I
wasn't on any sort of trajectory to be
on SNL and sometimes I would watch and
I'd be like
I feel like I could do it which was but
I only said it to myself never to anyone
else I know exactly what you mean who
was like the first person that said
something to you where you thought like
okay let me go pursue this thing my
friend Rachel was in the ground lanes
and I went and saw her in a show after
the show I was like I'm so happy because
now in and out of Towner comes in town I
have something to take them to an improv
show or a sketch show and she was like
yeah but also I wanted you to come
because I think you should take a class
and I was like but I'm not an actor and
she was like but you leave me seven
minute voicemails and character you
could do this yeah and then my brother I
told him I was like I have a friend who
thinks I should take improv and he was
like this is a very big brother thing to
do
um he said I've been waiting for you to
say that our whole lives I'll pay for
your classes that's amazing I know
that's amazing
so they came and saw me do a showcase at
the ground lanes and that was really
cool because
um I knew they were coming like I had a
week to prepare
and it was again at like my home field
and you know the Groundlings packed the
house with friends and family and
students and I had a really good
showcase I I felt good well you know I
felt I felt it in the moment and then
afterwards you're like I don't know and
you don't hear anything for two weeks
yeah and then I get a call that they
want to fly me out to New York and
they're like we wanted to do the exact
same set just do that um because it was
like producers and talent and then I'd
be going out you know for Lauren and
they're like that's the set we want
Lauren to see I go out there I'm feeling
good because I knew my set worked
um and I wanted to be undeniable I did
like 12 characters and was just like
this is that you know you have like four
minutes
um I don't remember any of that audition
because it was being a lifelong SNL fan
it was also the first time I'd ever been
in the studio and on the stage so like
they walked you out to the stage and as
prepared as I thought I was then
suddenly I'm like on the host stage like
where they do the monologues and so I'm
like I wanted to say like can I take a
picture and they're like five four three
and then I'm auditioning I do my
audition I feel good a week goes by we
get a call and they say we want her to
come back out this time she has to do a
totally new audition because I think
they want to know that you can turn over
material in a week
and that was cool and that's where all
the ground Lanes training really came in
because I was like I did everything I
did those 12 things like I don't know
those are like my like Heavy Hitters
yeah but then I got to be like oh okay
well what are like the characters I had
and sketches that didn't work like you
know that sketch might not have worked
at the ground Lanes but like that
character worked for even 10 seconds and
so I got to like play my bench in like
the second audition and that's the one I
really remember because I'm like oh
that's like my Motley Crew of characters
that I love and yeah and so then again I
fly home
um I see other people as I'm leaving to
go to the airport other people are
um that I knew had auditioned we stay
right across the street from 30 Rock I
see them going back to 30 Rock the next
day to go to meetings with Lauren and if
you read any SNL book you know that a
meeting with Lauren is a good thing yeah
I'm like texting my agency managers like
are you sure I should get on the plane
like do you think I might get a mating
they're like you've heard nothing I go
home I don't hear anything for 10 days
and on the 10th day I get a call from
him wow so I had grieved it I had
mourned it I had like it's not happening
yeah it's not my destiny yeah
foreign